directors Alfonso Cuaron and JJ Abrams
good morning for the first time in
Academy history we are announcing all 24
categories so let's begin for Best
Original Song the nominees are
everything is awesome from the lego
movie glory from Selma grateful from
beyond the lights I'm not going to miss
you from Glenn Campbell I'll be me and
lost stars from begin again for
achievement in visual effects the
nominees are Captain America the Winter
Soldier dawn of the Planet of the Apes
guardian of the galaxy interstellar an
x-men Days of Future past for Best
Documentary Short subject the enemy's
nominees are hmm crisis hotline veterans
press 1 Joanna
our curse the Reaper Lopaka
and white earth for Best Documentary
Feature the nominees are citizen for
finding my finding vivian maier last
days in vietnam the salt of the earth
and Beluga for achievement in film
editing the nominees are American sniper
boyhood the grand Budapest hotel the
imitation game and whiplash for
achievement in sound editing the
nominees are American sniper Birdman or
the unexpected virtue of ignorance they
hobbit the Bible of the five armies
interstellar and unbroken
for achievement in sound mixing the
nominees are American sniper Birdman or
the unexpected virtue of ignorance
interstellar unbroken and whiplash for
achievement in production design the
nominees are the grand Budapest hotel
the imitation game interstellar into the
woods
and mr Turner for Best live action short
film the nominees are aya Boogaloo and
Graham butter lamp the lamp Oh Bell
Dayak parvata and the phone call for
best animated short films the nominees
are the bigger picture the dam keeper
feast me and my molten and single life
for best animated feature film the
nominees are big hero 6 the boxtrolls
How to Train Your Dragon 2 song of the
sea and the tale of the Princess Kaguya
congratulations stay tuned for the
second part of our announcement with
Academy president Cheryl Boone Isaacs
and an actor named Chris Pine
[Applause]